[Music]
we break necks all the time
it's kind of like the deer in the
headlights look when they see us because
it's unexpected
[Music]
a bunch of brown indian boys walking
down fifth avenue in new york city and
killed says you don't see that every day
[Music]
my name is tushar patel i'm a backpack
player and pipe major for shreem of the
gym and swimming about the pipe band
located at sheree swaminathan temple in
sea caucus new jersey
the street strongman religion is a more
modern religion
it's a sect of hinduism that promotes
unity non-violence and peace and
well-being all throughout the world
music is definitely the fundamental of
our faith
our spiritual leader srimati given
spanish loved music
he fell in love with the sound of the
bagpipes
so he instructed us to start our own
bagpipe band
[Music]
no one had any idea how to play backpack
music
[Music]
we found online videos internet videos
we bought a bunch of intro to bagpipe
books
we didn't know any music but we knew
that if we worked together if we were
unified that we can do anything
[Music]
the sound of the bagpipes it's very
similar to some instruments that are
found in india
while we're playing scottish bagpipe
we're still playing indian music as well
as american music and music from all
around the world
being here in america we really wanted
to blend all the cultures that our band
represents
we like to maintain that traditional
scottish uniform but we also like to
blend in the indian and american culture
that uniqueness is what defines our band
there's really a sense of pride
we're proud of each other and proud of
where we've grown
it's not about only just playing the
backpipes
the reason that we play is to continue
spreading our message of peace and unity
through music
[Music]
bessie olive sally and jess have one
big thing in common
they all
love
jazz
[Music]
this is live oak florida a small town
west of jacksonville
not the type of place you associate with
jazz
and yet
there's ed
i'm a dairy farmer here in north florida
home to about 6 800 cows
that it
he can really blow
he's been playing trombone since
elementary school
but his audience has changed
this is his story
the first time i can remember the cows
coming up is i was just standing on the
backyard and and playing a trombone and
all the cows came up to the fence i had
a full audience
they're not particularly critical either
cows are very much creatures of habit
the music is something that's out of the
norm and that's why they're entertained
the cows have a an ability to understand
what's threatening and what's pleasing
and music is definitely pleasing to them
i have no idea if it's the one heifer
heard the music and the rest of them are
following the other heifer but it really
doesn't matter at the end of the day
we're all having a good time
my dad told me when we were kids he said
it's important from day one how we take
care of animals we like to consider
ourselves good stewards of the land good
stewards of the animals playing the
trombone is not any different than going
out and how we feed our cows and we take
care of our cows it's all about our
interaction with these animals our
animals they care
and so you play music to them they'll
remember that
[Music]
i watched myself die
i wanted to be a choir director
every hope
every dream that i had had was wrapped
around that center idea that i could
hear
and when that left
i had no idea how to live anymore
[Music]
i lost my earring when i was 18
and that's where
listening to music stopped
i've never heard taylor swift saying
i've never heard adele sing
i work really hard to feel things
i always have my shoes off when i
perform
because
as the drums go or the bass goes you
feel it through the floor
and that keeps me in time
and i was born
with near perfect pitch so i use that
skill mixed in with muscle memory to
feel
where i am
and then just sing
[Music]
i create songs all the time
i just have something in my head so i
just sing it in my recorder and then
i'll send it off to other people and
they can chart it for me and they can
tell me what the notes are because i
can't tell
i wouldn't be able to close my eyes and
tell you what it was
it's just a ghost
music is a ghost
[Music]
there it is
i had it that time
i spent a really long time of my life
being afraid
but
sound still exists you can feel music
everywhere
you just
focus
come walk my friend with me
[Music]
to place that we
always dream
you will know how it feels
[Music]
to be right where you're supposed to be
[Music]
all i say is you
holding me
forever
[Music]
come walk my friend with me
[Music]
to a place that we
always dreamed
[Music]
well i'm r stevie moore
i'm generally known
as one of the main pioneers of low
fidelity one-man band home recording
i've been recording for 50-something
years and i've made 400 albums in my
home
[Music]
yes i am our stevie moore back when i
was a younger child i started my own
idea of home recording by myself
my father was a bass player doing all
the country sessions with all the stars
of nashville
i had access to tape recorders in my
teenage basement and i was a huge rock
and roll fan and
absorbed all of these influences i
started messing around with writing
songs and making my own music
[Music]
do you record the privacy of your own
home is that correct that's right now
how do you do that well late 60s is when
i started making my little albums i over
dub all the instruments myself i play
bass and guitars and keyboards and
percussion and vocals
i got really good at it
i have to do 7 8 9 10 overdubs and you'd
still hear the very first thing that i
used
did you invent home recording of course
not but i took it to another level long
before it was customary
[Music]
i've probably written about four or five
thousand songs they came out
effortlessly
i would compile the most recent songs i
wouldn't pick and choose the best ones
and throw the worst ones on the floor
and that's been my aesthetic all along
it's like everything is released warts
and all because bad music is brilliant
it's a diary of sound
everybody that has ever been a record
collector loves to turn their pals on to
the obscure why do you hear this one i
mean i do have that reputation
talking heads and b-52s and we're all
fans of mine naturally a lot of these
big artists have found my music just
word of mouth but they never saw me
because i was the home hermit i know
what i'm doing i keep trying i keep
doing more of it i build up the quantity
without thinking about starting over at
the beginning to improve the quality
i hardly ever performed and i was a
bedroom guy it was always get home put
the headphones on
and then i would work for hours and
hours
in 2010 things started to explode out of
nowhere suddenly i was in a band and
touring the world i was playing hard
rock shows big festivals and tiny dives
was incredible my career really started
taking off
a little too late in life
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
often people say i can't see how you've
done this same thing all this time
without falling through
the trap
and by avoiding the mainstream nobody's
gonna dare tell me what i can and can't
do
feels so good to have that integrity
intact
i'm proud of all that and i'm also still
a little kid
[Music]
you